I agreed not to say this guy's name on the radio or the name of the small town that he's from, though he gave me a driving tour.
我同意不在电台里说出这个人的名字，也不透露他来自哪个小镇，尽管他带我开车游览了一番。
OK, now we're entering the great city of blank. So will you do, like, snazzy editing to make sure that I don't reveal? Because  I may accidentally, just as I'm talking.
好了，现在我们要进入“空白”这座伟大的城市了。你会进行精妙的剪辑来确保我不泄露信息吗？因为我在说话的时候可能会不小心说漏嘴。
Yes.
会。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. Now, we're sitting here in your car. How scared are you that somebody's going to see us together?
好。现在我们坐在你的车里。你有多担心被人看到我们在一起？
I'm not very scared about that. One thing, I'm driving in my mom's car, so it's not the car that  they would expect to see me in.
我对此不太担心。首先，我开的是我妈的车，所以这不是他们预料中会看到我开的车。
It's a Southern town, fewer than 2,000 people-- single-story homes, trucking companies, lots of cows, lots of churches. This guy doesn't want me to reveal who he is because he is a Democrat, and it's a secret in this overwhelmingly Republican town-- a very Christian, Fox-news-watching, Rush-Limbaugh-listening, evolution-disbelieving kind of town, the sort of town, he says, where  most people think that if America doesn't change its course, with all of its abortions and gay marriages--
这是一个南方小镇，人口不到2000人——有单层住宅、货运公司、很多牛、很多教堂。这个人不想让我透露他的身份，因为他是一名民主党人，而在这样一个绝大多数人都支持共和党的小镇里，这是一个秘密——这是一个非常传统的基督教小镇，人们看福克斯新闻、听拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）的节目、不相信进化论。他说，这种小镇的大多数人都认为，如果美国不改变方向，随着所有的堕胎和同性婚姻——
--either God will destroy America, or He'll have to reanimate Sodom and Gomorrah and apologize to them. If I had a dollar for every time that I've heard that, we would be going around in a convertible right now.
——要么上帝会摧毁美国，要么他就得复活索多玛和蛾摩拉，并向他们道歉。如果我每听到一次这种话就能赚一美元，我们现在早就在开敞篷车了。
Wait. I've never heard that. God would reanimate Sodom and Gomorrah and apologize?
等等。我从没听过这种说法。上帝会复活索多玛和蛾摩拉并向他们道歉？
Yeah, because He destroyed them for their sin and iniquity. And we're just as bad as Sodom and Gomorrah as far as they're concerned.
是的，因为他因他们的罪孽而毁灭了他们。而在他们看来，我们和索多玛、蛾摩拉一样糟糕。
He grew up in this town, believing all these things, but he doesn't believe them anymore-- the politics or the religion. And we're in a period in this country that lots of places-- in red states and in blue states-- people hear your politics, hear that they're different than theirs, and they don't think, well, we just disagree-- they think, you want to destroy this country and everything I believe in. In 2008, a close friend of his, a guy he sees in church several times a week, got a whiff, a hint of his political feelings.
他在这个小镇长大，曾经笃信这些，但他现在不再相信了——无论是政治还是宗教。我们国家正处于这样一个时期：许多地方——无论是在红州还是蓝州——人们听到你的政治立场，发现和你不同时，他们想的不是“我们只是意见不合”，而是“你想摧毁这个国家和我所信仰的一切”。2008年，他的一位密友，一个他每周在教堂见几次面的人，察觉到了他的政治倾向。
And he was just kind of taken aback and looked at me with wide eyes. And he said, you're voting for Obama, aren't you? And just the way he said that, it seemed like a scary question to answer. And so I didn't really answer, but that was answer enough. And we didn't talk for maybe three months after that. That kind of frightened me, just that reaction.
他当时有点吃惊，睁大了眼睛看着我。他说：“你投票给奥巴马，对吧？”他那样说的方式，让我觉得回答这个问题很可怕。所以我没有真正回答，但那已经算是回答了。从那以后，我们大概有三个月没说话。那反应让我感到害怕。
It frightened him into not wanting it to happen again. The guy in church agreed to keep his secret. And while this Democrat is somebody who everybody in town knows and most everybody likes-- he's this chatty friendly guy-- most people have no idea. He doesn't tell them because first, he has a business, and he doesn't want to lose customers.
这让他感到害怕，以至于不想再发生类似的事。那个教堂的朋友同意保守这个秘密。虽然这个民主党人是镇上人人都认识且大多都喜欢的人——他是一个健谈友善的人——但大多数人对此一无所知。他不告诉他们，首先是因为他有自己的生意，不想失去客户。
And second-- and here's how far this goes. I know how crazy this is going to sound-- he is an elected official, a city councilman. This town is so small that you don't have to declare a party when you run. And it's all budgets and basic services, so partisanship doesn't come up. So his constituents don't know.
其次——这是最令人难以置信的——他是民选官员，市议会议员。这个镇太小了，竞选时不需要申报党派。而且全是关于预算和基本服务，所以党派之争不会出现。所以他的选民们并不知道。
I do find myself lying sometimes. But I honestly do try and not lie. I try and just let them assume. And that has a great-- which is, I know in its way-- lie. But the most I can do that, I try.
我确实发现自己有时会撒谎。但我确实在尽力不撒谎。我尝试让他们去猜测。我知道这在某种程度上也是撒谎。但我尽可能地避免这样做。
And people assume-- especially if somebody likes you or they think that you're smart-- they assume that you agree with what they think. That's a natural human thing, right? Like, I assume that you're an agnostic liberal.
人们会猜测——特别是如果有人喜欢你或者认为你很聪明时——他们会认为你同意他们的观点。这是一种自然的人类本能，对吧？就像我假设你是一个不可知论的自由派一样。
Thanks a lot.
多谢了。
Yeah, you're welcome.
不用谢。
He says with the election coming, he finds himself biting his tongue a lot more. It's harder on him as a secret blue sympathizer. And we talked about this for a long time. Wasn't he just being a coward, not being more honest with people? Wasn't he kind of giving up on people, believing that they were going to drop him if they knew his politics.
他说随着选举临近，他发现自己需要更多地保持沉默。作为一名秘密的蓝营支持者，他感到压力更大。我们对此进行了长时间的探讨。他难道不是在当懦夫，不敢对人们更坦诚吗？他难道不是在放弃这些人，认为只要他们知道了他的政治立场就会抛弃他吗？
I mean, it's funny because this is what's supposed to be so great about this country, is that we can believe real different things and get along fine-- do community activities together, do stuff together, be friends-- I mean, that's what's supposed to be so great about America.
我是说，这很有趣，因为这应该是这个国家最伟大之处，即我们可以拥有完全不同的信仰却能和平相处——一起参加社区活动，一起做事，做朋友——我是说，这应该是美国最伟大的地方。
And do you believe that's true? I mean, I know that's the theory, but do you think that's true?
你相信这是真的吗？我的意思是，我知道那是理论，但你认为这是真的吗？
As we here at This American Life talked about next week's election and what we wanted to cover here on the air about it, we found ourselves thinking about and distressed over these past few months-- it was the incredible gap between the two sides right now, between red and blue. It's not just that they have different solutions to the country's problems. They don't even agree on what the problems are. Entire scandals are covered for weeks in the right-wing media that people on the left barely even know about. Crises that are a given on the left, like climate change, aren't even acknowledged as real by so many on the right-- with lots of people on each side seeing the other side as stupid, ill-formed, a menace-- it's frightening. That's how far it has gone.
当我们这些《美国生活》（This American Life）的人谈论下周的选举以及我们想在节目中报道的内容时，我们发现自己对过去几个月的情况感到困扰——现在双方之间的巨大鸿沟，红营和蓝营之间。这不仅仅是他们对国家问题有不同的解决方案。他们甚至不同意问题到底是什么。右翼媒体报道了数周的丑闻，左翼的人几乎闻所未闻。而左翼认为理所当然的危机，比如气候变化，在右翼看来却根本不是事实——每一方都有很多人把另一方看作愚蠢、无知、甚至是威胁——这太可怕了。情况已经恶化到了这种程度。
So today, we are spending this hour looking at these two different versions of the world-- red America and blue America-- trying to understand what it is doing to people to be living this way now. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stick around, huh?
所以今天，我们将花一个小时来观察这两种不同的世界版本——红色的美国和蓝色的美国——试图了解现在这样生活对人们造成了什么影响。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请留下来，好吗？
Act One, "I Know You Are, But What Am I?" So the idea for this show began really with a question-- the divisiveness in our country, the fact that things are so polarized, to what degree is it pushing people apart in their personal lives, messing with friendships, straining family relations? To answer that, in addition to all the normal reporterly things that a person does, with the help of American Public Media's Public Insight Network, we sent out a questionnaire. Over 500 people responded from every part of the political spectrum. Lisa Pollak explains what we learned.
第一幕，“我知道你是谁，但我是谁？”所以这期节目的构思源于一个问题——我们国家的这种分歧，两极分化的现状，在多大程度上破坏了人们的个人生活、干扰了友谊、使家庭关系变得紧张？为了回答这个问题，除了记者通常做的那些工作外，在美国公共媒体“公共洞察网络”的帮助下，我们发出了一份问卷。来自政治光谱各个角落的500多人做出了回应。莉莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）来解释我们的发现。
Before we get to the discouraging parts of the story-- the estranged friends, the embittered relatives, the casual comparison of the other guy's party to the Nazis-- I want to pause for a moment and pay tribute to a group of people who don't get a lot of press these days. I'm talking about the people who wrote us to say that their red-blue relationships have not only survived this election season but are as amicable and harmonious as ever. No one seemed happier than the self-described Democrat bordering on Socialist married to a Libertarian-minded Republican who wrote, quote, "Our discussions are rarely heated or unpleasant and our ability to have a conversation where we have differing points of view has actually strengthened the relationship." Kudos to them and to all of you who've managed to do what our lawmakers haven't.
在我们谈论这个故事令人沮丧的部分之前——疏远的朋友、反目成仇的亲戚、随意将对方党派比作纳粹——我想暂停一下，向一群最近没得到多少关注的人致敬。我说的是那些写信告诉我们，他们的红蓝关系不仅在这次选举季幸存下来，而且依然像往常一样和睦和谐的人。没有谁比一位自称是接近社会主义者的民主党人、且嫁给了一位自由意志主义共和党人的女性更开心了，她写道：“我们的讨论很少激烈或不愉快，我们能够就不同观点进行交流的能力，实际上加强了我们的关系。”向他们以及所有能够做到我们议员们所没能做到之事的人致敬。
But this story isn't about you, nor is it about the people who told us they avoid the subject of politics entirely, the "don't ask, don't tell" method of keeping the peace. This story is about the people who did ask and did tell and suffered the consequences, people like Frank Mills, a Democrat, and Ron Sexton, a Republican.
但这个故事不是关于你们的，也不是关于那些告诉我们完全避开政治话题的人，那种用“不问也不说”的方法来维持和平的人。这个故事是关于那些确实问了、确实说了，并遭受了后果的人，比如民主党人弗兰克·米尔斯（Frank Mills）和共和党人罗恩·塞克斯顿（Ron Sexton）。
Frank and Ron met at work decades ago, and their families became friends too. They live in different cities now, but a couple times a year, after their wives caught up on the phone, the guys would get on the line and talk politics.
弗兰克和罗恩几十年前在工作中相识，他们的家庭也成了朋友。他们现在住在不同的城市，但一年几次，在他们的妻子在电话里叙旧后，这两个男人会通电话谈论政治。
We talked about policy, we talked about the issues, and we would talk for hours. The phone would go dead. I'd have to get another phone. The battery ran down.
我们讨论政策，讨论时事，我们可以聊上几个小时。电话打到没电，我不得不换个电话。电池耗尽了。
They didn't talk about the day-to-day stuff of elections and candidates, Frank said, as much as political philosophies and big ideas.
弗兰克说，他们谈论选举和候选人的日常事务并不多，更多的是谈论政治哲学和宏大思想。
It was never settled. You have your opinion, I have my opinion, and this is the way it is, and I'll call you next time.
这从未有定论。你有你的观点，我有我的观点，事情就是这样，下次再打给你。
So it was good? It was a good relationship?
所以这很好？这是一段很好的友谊？
Oh, it was really great. I loved it.
哦，真的很棒。我很喜欢。
But then, a few years ago, they were talking on the phone. And Ron urged Frank to support a Republican candidate for Congress. Frank balked. Didn't Ron know he supported Democrats?
但几年前，他们在电话里聊天时，罗恩敦促弗兰克支持一位共和党国会候选人。弗兰克拒绝了。难道罗恩不知道他支持民主党人吗？
And he said, who did you vote for for president? And I said, I voted for Obama.
他说：“你总统投给了谁？”我说：“我投给了奥巴马。”
Apparently this had not come up before.
显然，这个问题以前从未涉及过。
And then he said, you must be a Socialist.
然后他说：“你一定是社会主义者。”
He said this seriously or jokingly?
他是认真说的还是开玩笑？
No, seriously. You must be a Socialist. And I said, how can you make that assumption? He says, well, you voted for Obama. He's a socialist, and therefore you are. And then I took it as if he had called me a dirty name. And we got into an argument. And then after a while, he said, well, I'm writing you off my list, Frank. Don't ever talk to me again. You're no longer a friend of mine, is how that conversation ended.
不，是认真的。你一定是社会主义者。我说：“你怎么能这样假设？”他说：“好吧，你投给了奥巴马。他是社会主义者，所以你也是。”我把它当成了他在骂我脏话。我们吵了起来。过了一会儿，他说：“好吧，弗兰克，我把你从名单上删除了。永远别再跟我说话了。你不再是我的朋友了。”谈话就这样结束了。
Weeks passed, and to Frank, things didn't feel right. So he decided to try again.
几周过去了，对弗兰克来说，感觉不对劲。所以他决定再试一次。
I called him, and I said, can we restart all these conversations we've had over the years? I don't want to lose you as a friend. If I offended you, I'm sorry. He would not accept that at all. At that point, I retaliated. I said, OK, if you've written me off, I'm writing you off. You won't hear from me again.
我打电话给他，说：“我们能重启多年来的这些对话吗？我不想失去你这个朋友。如果我冒犯了你，我很抱歉。”他完全不接受。在那一刻，我也反击了。我说：“好吧，如果你把我划掉了，那我也把你划掉。你不会再听到我的消息了。”
He's funny, he's got a good intellect, but he cannot look me in the eye and have any credibility with me describing Obama the way he does.
他很有趣，很有头脑，但他无法直视我的眼睛，也没有任何可信度，因为他那样描述奥巴马。
It probably won't surprise you to hear that Ron and Frank don't remember all the details of this story the same way. Ron says he doesn't recall telling Frank never to call again. But when I brought up the S word, Ron didn't hesitate.
听到罗恩和弗兰克对这个故事的细节记忆不完全相同，你可能不会感到惊讶。罗恩说他不记得告诉过弗兰克永远不要再打电话。但当我提起“社会主义者”这个词时，罗恩毫不犹豫。
Frank recalls you calling him a Socialist.
弗兰克记得你称他为社会主义者。
Absolutely. And I did, and I still believe it. When Frank takes umbrage at the fact that I called him a Socialist, what he doesn't understand or doesn't accept is that he is in love with a Socialist. This man that's in the White House is the most brilliant president we've ever had for Frank Mills and others like some of his friends. And Lisa, it offends me to hear that while we're going down the tubes.
绝对是的。而且我确实这么说了，现在仍然这么认为。当弗兰克因为我称他为社会主义者而感到愤怒时，他没有理解或不接受的是，他爱上了一个社会主义者。白宫里的那个人对弗兰克·米尔斯和他的某些朋友来说是最卓越的总统。莉莎，听到这些让我感到愤怒，因为我们正在走下坡路。
He says his feelings were hurt. Why not just agree to disagree and put those differences aside? Why is that hard?
他说他感到受伤了。为什么不求同存异，把分歧放在一边呢？为什么这很难？
I would lay it on this-- the stakes are too high to consider it simply as agree to disagree. I don't agree to disagree. Frank needs to change his opinion because his view on the conduct of this society will kill it.
我会这么说——风险太高了，不能简单地看作是求同存异。我不求同存异。弗兰克需要改变他的观点，因为他对这个社会运作的看法会毁了它。
For a friendship to end, this is all you need-- one person who feels like the stakes are too high to ignore or that your friend's vote will personally harm you. A few months ago, a man named Navi Singh was so distraught that he did a Google search on three words-- friendship ruined in politics. And given the mood these days, it didn't take long for him to find a blog where people were discussing the subject. And in the comments, he told strangers his story. That's where I found him.
一段友谊的终结，只需要这些——一个人觉得风险太高而不容忽视，或者觉得朋友的选票会对自己造成人身伤害。几个月前，一个叫纳维·辛格（Navi Singh）的人因为极度苦恼，在谷歌上搜索了三个词——“政治毁了友谊”。考虑到现在的情绪，他很快就找到了一个人们讨论这个话题的博客。在评论区，他向陌生人讲述了自己的故事。我就是在那里找到他的。
Navi has a blood disease that requires monthly transfusions. And recently, he tried to buy insurance and was turned down everywhere because of his pre-existing condition. After that, Navi began to see next week's election as a matter of life and death. He considers Obamacare his lifeline, and he doesn't trust Mitt Romney.
纳维患有一种需要每月输血的血液疾病。最近，他试图购买保险，但因为他已有的健康状况到处都被拒之门外。从那以后，纳维开始把下周的选举看作关乎生死的议题。他认为奥巴马医改是他的救命稻草，他不信任米特·罗姆尼。
Navi has a Republican friend, and in past years, he never cared who his friend voted for. But this year, he wanted his friend to take a side, vote Obama. But when he tried to explain this, he got nowhere.
纳维有一位共和党朋友，过去几年他从不在乎他的朋友投票给谁。但今年，他希望他的朋友能选边站，投票给奥巴马。但当他试图解释时，他处处碰壁。
I mean, no matter what kind of evidence I showed him and all of the rejection letters I showed him, and then he's like, OK, I see that. I see that. But in the end, you obviously know I'm still voting for Romney. I'm still voting for Romney. And it hurt. It really hurt. I know he probably didn't mean to, but in a way, the only way you can take it as a friend is this person doesn't value your life. He sees it, and he kind of nods his head, yeah, that's a shame. But in the end, he'll still vote that way.
我的意思是，无论我给他看什么样的证据，给他看多少封拒绝信，他都说：“好的，我看到了。我看到了。但最后，你显然知道我还是会投票给罗姆尼。我还是会投罗姆尼。”这很伤人。真的很伤人。我知道他可能不是故意的，但从某种程度上说，作为朋友，你唯一能感受到的就是，这个人根本不重视你的生命。他看到了，然后点点头说：“是啊，那太遗憾了。”但最后，他还是会那样投票。
I said, I can't do this anymore. He called me one time and was like, let's go out and hang out. I was like, you know what? I don't even enjoy myself with you anymore. This election is so personal, and I've down everything. If you're valuing me as a friend, you would understand this. And you know, then, I was like, oh, forget it. I mean, he didn't want the friendship to end. I'm the one who ended it.
我说：“我受够了。”他有一次打电话给我说：“出去聚聚吧。”我说：“你知道吗？和你在一起我一点都不开心。这次选举太个人化了，我已经尽了一切努力。如果你把我当朋友，你应该理解这一点。”然后我就说：“哦，算了吧。”他不想让友谊结束。是我结束了这段友谊。
I'm the enemy. I'm what's wrong with this world.
我是敌人。我是这个世界上不正常的原因。
This is Erik Shetney from Minneapolis. As a red in a blue city, he says he's used to liberal colleagues reducing him to a cliche.
这是来自明尼阿波利斯的埃里克·谢特尼（Erik Shetney）。作为一个在蓝色城市里的红营人士，他说他习惯了自由派同事将他贬低为陈词滥调。
I'm opposed to the middle class. I am completely supportive of the concept of a robber baron, almost from the Gilded Age in the 1890s, that I am all about making rich people richer. And I think it's acceptable to do this at the expense of poor people who consume government services.
我反对中产阶级。我完全支持19世纪90年代镀金时代的强盗男爵概念，我所做的一切就是让富人更富。我认为以牺牲消耗政府服务穷人的代价来这样做是可以接受的。
A lot of Democrats just assume I don't understand the issues and if only I was better educated on them, I would believe like they do.
很多民主党人只是假设我不懂这些问题，如果我在这些问题上受过更好的教育，我就会和他们有一样的信念。
That's a woman I'll call Anne. Last year she heard about an opening in a friend's hiking group and asked to join only to be told by her friend in front of a group of other friends that she wouldn't be welcome because she was a Republican.
那是我称之为安妮的女性。去年，她听说朋友的徒步小组有空缺并要求加入，结果却被朋友当着其他朋友的面告知，因为她是共和党人，所以不欢迎她。
It was one of those horrible, awkward moments where just the room went quiet. In their minds or her mind, Republicans are all that's wrong with the world.
那是那种可怕、尴尬的时刻之一，房间里安静了下来。在他们的心目中，共和党人是这个世界上一切问题的根源。
The most creative rejection of a friend's politics I heard was this-- a man named Drew wrote to say that he got an ultimatum from his friend, Ryan. The two guys are married to sisters and hang out together all the time. But if Drew votes for Obama, Ryan has put him on notice. There will be consequences. Drew explains.
我听过的对朋友政治立场最富创造力的拒绝方式是这个——一个叫德鲁的人写信说，他收到了朋友莱恩的最后通牒。这两个人娶了姐妹俩，总是混在一起。但如果德鲁投票给奥巴马，莱恩已经告知他。后果自负。德鲁解释道。
If you vote for Obama, you're cut off. You can still come over to our house and eat, but when I cook ribs, you can bring your own chicken breast and use the grill after I'm done. And at first I thought he was just kidding around, but he's made it clear that he's absolutely serious. And I appealed to his wife, and she said, well, I got to stand with my husband.
如果你投票给奥巴马，你就被切断了联系。你仍然可以来我家吃饭，但当我做排骨时，你可以自带鸡胸肉，等我做完后再用烤架。起初我以为他只是在开玩笑，但他明确表示他是完全认真的。我向他的妻子求助，她说，嗯，我必须支持我的丈夫。
Wait. He was totally serious that you couldn't eat his barbecue if you voted for Obama?
等等。他完全是认真的，如果你投票给奥巴马，就不能吃他的烧烤？
Absolutely serious.
完全认真。
Yep, he's got to cook his own meat for the next four years.
是的，未来四年他得自己烤肉。
This is Ryan.
这是莱恩。
I know he loves my barbecue so much. And I was thinking one day. You know, I've tried to explain to Drew why he shouldn't vote Democratic, but I can't get through to him. So now I'm going to do a little negative reinforcement. And if he votes for him, I'm just not going to let him eat here. And my wife makes salad or garlic bread or beans-- he can have that. He just cannot eat my meat-- my tri-tip, my ribs, my pulled pork, my brisket, I make a wonderful prime rib sandwich-- he can't have any of that.
我知道他非常喜欢我的烧烤。有一天我在想。你知道，我试着向德鲁解释他为什么不应该投票给民主党人，但我无法说服他。所以现在我要进行一些负面强化。如果他投票给奥巴马，我就不让他在这里吃东西。我妻子做的沙拉、大蒜面包或豆子——他可以吃那个。他就是不能吃我的肉——我的三角牛排、排骨、手撕猪肉、牛腩，我做的优质肋眼三明治——他一样都不能吃。
For two sides that sometimes seem to be living in completely different realities, it's amazing how many of the reds and blues I talked to express the exact same feelings about each other in the exact same words. In fact, I could tell the relationship was probably on the rocks when the interview included at least one of the following elements. One, total incomprehension about the other person's beliefs.
对于有时看起来生活在完全不同现实中的两个阵营来说，令人惊讶的是，我采访的那么多红营和蓝营人士表达的感受竟然如此相同。事实上，当采访包含以下至少一个要素时，我就能看出这段关系可能处于破裂边缘。第一，对对方的信仰完全无法理解。
I couldn't believe somebody could actually really think that.
我不敢相信竟然有人真的会那样想。
Like, I don't even know who you are anymore.
比如，我甚至不知道你到底是谁了。
He can't truly feel the way he feels. There's absolutely no way.
他不可能真的那样感受。绝对不可能。
Two, a declaration of one's superior powers of open-mindedness.
第二，声明自己拥有优越的开明思想。
Liberals in general are more open to another person's point of view than conservatives are.
自由派通常比保守派更能接受他人的观点。
The Democrats I know tend to be much more lockstep-- this is the right way.
我认识的民主党人往往更死板——这才是正确的方式。
Three, communication problems.
第三，沟通问题。
I don't even think she's even tried to look at my beliefs. And I can't say that I have tried that hard to look at hers.
我甚至认为她根本没试着去看我的信仰。而我也不能说我有多努力地去看她的。
You don't feel like he listens to you?
你不觉得他听你说话吗？
No. No, not at all. And in his defense, I mean, a lot of times, I kinda tune him out too.
不。不，完全没有。在为他辩护的时候，我的意思是，很多时候，我也会忽略他。
And finally, four, yes, inevitably, references to the Nazis.
最后，第四，是的，不可避免地，提到了纳粹。
I don't care how long Ayers teaches at the University of Chicago. To deny Ayers' violence toward the United States of America is to deny that Eichmann had anything to do with the mass murders of Jews.
我不在乎艾尔斯（Ayers）在芝加哥大学教了多久。否认艾尔斯对美国施加的暴力，就是否认艾希曼与犹太人大屠杀有关。
It was like a Jewish person voting for Hitler.
这就像犹太人投票给希特勒一样。
If the Nazi party were in power, are we going to compromise with them just because they're half of the country? I know that I have just made an analogy between the Republican Party and the Nazis. I understand that.
如果纳粹党掌权，我们是否要因为他们代表了半个国家就妥协？我知道我刚刚把共和党和纳粹做了一个类比。我明白这一点。
Of all the situations I heard about, this next one stumped me most because both people wanted things to be different between them. But it was hard to fathom how they possibly could be. Janet, a conservative from Kentucky, wrote us about her sister.
在我听到的所有情况中，下面这个让我最难过，因为双方都希望他们之间的关系能有所改变。但很难想象这怎么可能。来自肯塔基州的保守派珍妮特（Janet）给我们写信讲述了她妹妹的事。
She and I have been close, and I've been able to talk to her and stuff. I don't talk to her much anymore. I don't call her because I'm afraid something will come up and we'll get mad at each other. And so we just kind of avoid talking to each other. Probably within the last month, I thought, well, I'll just call Suzie and talk to her. And then I'm like, nah, I'd best not. About nothing important, just to call and say, I tried a new recipe. You want to hear how it went? Just any of that kind of stuff.
她和我曾经很亲密，我以前能和她聊天什么的。我现在不怎么和她说话了。我不给她打电话，因为我怕谈到什么事，然后我们会对彼此生气。所以我们只是避免互相交谈。大概在上个月，我想，好吧，我会给苏西打个电话和她聊聊。然后我想，不，最好别打了。也没什么重要的事，只是打个电话说，我尝试了一个新食谱。你想听听结果如何吗？随便聊聊这些。
Janet's active in the Republican Party, though she considers herself more of a Libertarian. She attended the 9/12 taxpayers' march on Washington a few years back. Her sister Susan is a Democrat. Last spring, they went on a trip together and Obamacare came up.
珍妮特活跃于共和党，尽管她认为自己更倾向于自由意志主义。几年前，她参加了华盛顿的“9/12纳税人游行”。她的妹妹苏珊（Susan）是民主党人。去年春天，她们一起去旅行，聊到了奥巴马医改。
I mean, it just turned into a yelling match. And it didn't take but half a second. It was more like, somebody's got to do something. And it's, well, OK, do something, but this is not the thing to do. Well, you don't care. You want all these people to die. And it just devolved so quickly.
我的意思是，它直接变成了一场争吵。而且只用了半秒钟。更像是，某人必须做点什么。然后是，好吧，做点什么，但这绝对不是该做的事。好吧，你不在乎。你想要所有这些人去死。一切都恶化得太快了。
She and Susan always had different politics, but after Obama got elected, it was hard to talk about that stuff without fighting. If I say anything, oh, you're a bigot. You just don't like him because he's black. And those kind of things are hurtful. And so I just get mad that she can't see what he's doing to this country. And I guess she gets mad at me that she thinks everybody ought to have a handout. I don't know when it's gotten this bad.
她和苏珊的政治观点一直不同，但奥巴马当选后，不吵架就很难讨论这些事情。如果我说什么，哦，你是个偏执狂。你只是因为他是黑人而不喜欢他。这些话很伤人。所以我很生气，她看不出他对这个国家正在做什么。我想她因为认为每个人都应该得到救济而对我生气。我不知道情况是从什么时候变得这么糟糕的。
When I called Susan, she sounded just as frustrated as her sister.
当我打电话给苏珊时，她听起来和她的姐姐一样沮丧。
I'm probably the worst one of the problem we have. It's probably mostly me because her dogmatic ideology just drives me insane. I'm not trying to hurt her feelings. I don't want to hurt her feelings. I just can't believe what comes out of her mouth.
我可能是我们所面临的问题中最糟糕的一个。大概大部分原因在我，因为她那教条式的意识形态让我抓狂。我不想伤害她的感情。我不想伤害她的感情。但我无法相信从她嘴里说出的话。
Susan told me she wished she and Janet could talk-- really talk and try to understand each other. But she couldn't see how that was going to happen, and I didn't either. And then I heard this.
苏珊告诉我，她希望她和珍妮特能交谈——真正地谈谈并试图理解对方。但她看不出这怎么能发生，我也不行。然后我听到了这个。
Coming up after the news, a conservative, a liberal, and a search for common ground. Today's guests don't agree on many things, but at least they develop the ability to talk to each other and even disagree while still being pleasant. Phil Neisser, the liberal, and Jacob Hess, the conservative, even wrote a book together based on their method for dialogue. It's called, You're Not as Crazy as I Thought, But You're Still Wrong.
新闻之后即将播出：保守派、自由派以及对共同点的寻找。今天的嘉宾在许多事情上意见不合，但至少他们培养了交谈、甚至在不同意时仍能保持愉悦的能力。自由派菲尔·奈瑟（Phil Neisser）和保守派雅各布·赫斯（Jacob Hess）甚至根据他们的方法写了一本书。书名叫《你没有我想象的那么疯，但你依然是错的》。
If you're feeling a bit skeptical about this lead-in, let me assure you, I was too. But the book isn't a gimmick, and its authors aren't the hand-holding, political moderates you might expect. Jacob's a devout Mormon, pro-life, very conservative on most issues. Phil's a die-hard liberal, an atheist, pro-choice.
如果你对这个开场白感到有点怀疑，让我向你保证，我当时也一样。但这本书不是个噱头，它的作者也不是那种你可能预料到的那种左右逢源的政治中间派。雅各布是一名虔诚的摩门教徒，反堕胎，在大多数问题上非常保守。菲尔是一个死硬的自由派，无神论者，支持堕胎选择。
The kind of dialogue that Phil and Jacob are encouraging isn't about compromise. It isn't touchy-feely, but it's also not like debate. In fact, for it to work, they say, you have to back off of the main goal most people have in political conversations-- persuading the other person to think like you do. Instead, you focus on trying to understand what the person believes and why he or she believes it. The other person does the same for you. Phil and Jacob say that for them, this led to difficult, uncomfortable conversations, but they ended up viewing each other more generously.
菲尔和雅各布所鼓励的那种对话不是关于妥协的。它不是那种煽情的内容，但也不像辩论。事实上，他们说，为了让它起作用，你必须放弃大多数人在政治对话中拥有的主要目标——说服对方像你一样思考。相反，你专注于试图理解对方相信什么以及为什么相信。对方也为你做同样的事。菲尔和雅各布说，对他们来说，这导致了困难、不舒服的对话，但他们最终更宽容地看待对方。
I wanted to see this in action, so I arranged for the two sisters, Janet and Susan, to get on a conference call with Phil and Jacob and try out some of their techniques. They agreed to let me listen in and record the conversation.
我想看看这在实践中如何，所以我安排了两姐妹珍妮特和苏珊参加一个电话会议，尝试一下他们的一些技巧。她们同意让我监听并录下对话。
But the night before this was supposed to happen, Janet, the conservative sister, got cold feet. She left a message that she was backing out, that she feared she'd say something she couldn't take back. So I convinced her to get on the phone without Susan and hear what the dialogue guys had to say. Right off the bat, Janet admitted that her goal with her sister was exactly the opposite of Phil and Jacob's.
但在原本预定要发生的前一晚，保守派姐姐珍妮特退缩了。她留言说她要退出，因为她害怕自己会说出无法收回的话。所以我说服她不带苏珊打这个电话，听听这些对话专家的说法。一开始，珍妮特就承认她和她妹妹的对话目标正好和菲尔与雅各布的目标相反。
I was looking for the conversation to fix her and make her understand what's wrong with her thinking.
我一直想通过对话来“修复”她，让她明白她的想法有什么问题。
Aha, There's the rub.
啊哈，这就是关键所在。
That's probably half the goal.
这大概是目标的一半。
The three of them talked for an hour. She tried to explain why it was so hard for her to accept her sister's views. Here she is with Phil, the liberal.
三个人谈了一个小时。她试着解释为什么接受她妹妹的观点那么难。这是她和自由派菲尔的对话。
I guess I see most liberals as being selfish, and she's not selfish. And so that's what makes me so aggravated is that these liberals can be so selfish, and she's not one. And I'm just like, you're not that heartless. You cannot be there.
我想我把大多数自由派看作是自私的，而她并不自私。所以这让我感到非常恼火的是，这些自由派怎么能如此自私，而她不是。我就觉得，你不是那么铁石心肠。你不可能是那样。
Where do you get the idea that liberals are selfish? I'm curious.
你从哪里得出自由派很自私这个观点的？我很好奇。
Because they don't want to do anything to take care of people. They just want somebody else to. They want the government to. And she doesn't. She's just so giving and loving, and she'll give anybody the shirt off her back and the shoes off her feet.
因为他们不想做任何照顾人的事。他们只想要别人去做。他们想要政府去做。而她不是那样。她非常慷慨和充满爱心，她可以把衬衫脱下来送给任何人，鞋子也一样。
I want to tell you a little bit about how it is I approach Jacob. The vision was, I'll bet you he's not selfish. I'll bet you he's not greedy. I think most people in the whole world are not selfish, they're not greedy. Many of them believe the wrong things. That's my view, right? They believe the wrong things. They believe I believe the wrong things.
我想告诉你一点我是如何对待雅各布的。愿景是，我敢打赌他不自私。我敢打赌他不贪婪。我认为世界上大多数人都不自私，他们不贪婪。他们中的许多人相信了错误的东西。这是我的观点，对吧？他们相信了错误的东西。他们认为我相信了错误的东西。
But if you have this story in your head that liberals are selfish, why would you talk to any of them? You know what I mean? So maybe liberals in general, and conservatives, we disagree with each other. And one of us is right and one of us is wrong, but none of us are selfish. What about that idea?
但如果你的脑子里有“自由派很自私”这个故事，你为什么要和他们中的任何一个说话呢？你明白我的意思吗？所以也许自由派和保守派，我们彼此不同意。我们中一个是正确的，一个是错误的，但我们谁都不自私。那个主意怎么样？
Yeah, well that's--
是的，嗯，那是——
Food for thought.
值得思考。
I don't know if this will change things for Janet and Susan, but I can tell you that by the end of the conversation, Janet-- to my surprise-- sounded hopeful.
我不知道这是否会改变珍妮特和苏珊的情况，但我可以告诉你，在对话结束时，珍妮特——让我惊讶的是——听起来充满了希望。
I'm already thinking about things I can write her in an email and say, we need to get together, and we need to sit down and talk, and what can we do? I'm very hopeful.
我已经在考虑我可以给她写封电子邮件说，我们需要聚一聚，我们需要坐下来谈谈，我们可以做些什么？我非常有希望。
What's the thing they said that made you feel that way?
他们说了什么让你有这种感觉？
Well, it reminded me, I guess, that I'm not going to change her. I mean, I can't make her see, but maybe before we start a conversation, let's have a hug and kiss and remember if yelling starts, we've got to do something to stop it.
嗯，它提醒了我，我想，我不能改变她。我的意思是，我不能强迫她明白，但也许在我们开始谈话之前，让我们先拥抱一下，亲吻一下，记住如果开始大喊大叫，我们必须做点什么来阻止它。
To Phil and Jacob, the problem isn't that people disagree, it's the way they do it. I saw this in so many people's stories. There was the woman whose parents said she could stay rent free with them during grad school as long as she signed a contract vowing to vote for Mitt Romney and the Obama voter who felt so betrayed by his son's support of Romney that he told him not to come by the house until the election is over. One man wrote us hours after he'd been defriended by his mother on Facebook. Why did she defriend him? Because when she posted that her support for Romney was purely about the economy, he wrote, quote, "To all the Jews, gypsies, Communists, and homosexuals, my vote for the Nazi party has nothing to do with you. I just wanted the trains to run on time." He wrote us that his biggest regret was mixing the two historical references.
对于菲尔和雅各布来说，问题不在于人们有分歧，而在于他们表达分歧的方式。我在很多人的故事中看到了这一点。有一位女士，她的父母说只要她签了一份发誓投票给米特·罗姆尼的合同，她研究生期间就可以住在家里免租金；还有那位奥巴马的选民，他感到被儿子对罗姆尼的支持背叛了，以至于他告诉儿子在选举结束前不要到家里来。有一个人在他妈妈在Facebook上把他删掉好友的几小时后给我们写信。她为什么要删掉他？因为当她贴出她对罗姆尼的支持纯粹是关于经济时，他写道：“致所有的犹太人、吉普赛人、共产主义者和同性恋者，我投给纳粹党的票与你们无关。我只是想让火车准时运行。”他写信给我们说，他最后悔的是把这两个历史参考混为一谈。
But my favorite story was about a campaign sign. Last month, on a street in a town in the battleground state of Ohio, a woman and her husband decided to put out a Mitt Romney sign. The woman, knowing that her neighbors were Obama supporters, worried what they'd think of her. She considered them friends, and she didn't want things to get awkward or uncomfortable.
但我最喜欢的故事是关于一个竞选标志。上个月，在俄亥俄州这个摇摆州的一个小镇街道上，一位女士和她的丈夫决定竖起一个米特·罗姆尼的标志。这位女士知道邻居们是奥巴马的支持者，她担心他们会怎么看她。她认为他们是朋友，不想让事情变得尴尬或不舒服。
So after she put out the sign, she wrote her neighbors an email explaining just that, telling them how much she valued their friendship and that she didn't want politics to come between them. And at a time when so many people are either fighting or staying quiet, feeling weird about their differences, this small act struck me as incredibly honest and disarming. And her neighbors wrote her back to say of course, the sign was fine.
所以竖起标志后，她给邻居们写了一封电子邮件解释了这一点，告诉他们她多么珍惜他们的友谊，不想让政治插在他们中间。在这样一个许多人要么吵架要么保持沉默、对彼此的分歧感到奇怪的时代，这种微小的行为让我觉得极其诚实和令人放下戒心。她的邻居们回信说，当然，这个标志没问题。
Lisa Pollak's one of the producers of our show. If you would like to be part of APM's Public Insight Network, which helped Lisa find some of her interviewees and which invites everyone to share their stories confidentially with journalists, go to publicinsightnetwork.org. Coming up, how two little words could upset an entire state legislature, and the words are not even in English. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
莉莎·波拉克是我们节目的制作人之一。如果你想成为APM“公共洞察网络”的一员（该网络帮助莉莎找到了她的一些受访者，并邀请每个人私下与记者分享他们的故事），请访问publicinsightnetwork.org。接下来，两个小词是如何搅乱整个州议会的，而且这两个词甚至不是英文。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, in the lead up to Tuesday's election, we have stories about the divide between red America and blue America. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, "Nothing in Moderation."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，在周二选举前夕，我们要讲述关于红色美国和蓝色美国之间鸿沟的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“没有任何温和”。
So the polarization of our country has spread far and wide. People in the middle are being squeezed out, starting in the US Congress, where Democrats who lean to the right-- the Blue Dog Democrats-- are nearly extinct. And the few remaining Republicans who are willing to compromise with the left-- like Olympia Snow of Maine-- are stepping down or being targeted for defeat by their own party and right-leaning special interest groups.
所以，我们国家的两极分化已经四处蔓延。中间派正在被挤压，始于美国国会，那里倾向右翼的民主党人——蓝狗民主党人——几乎灭绝了。而剩下的少数愿意与左翼妥协的共和党人——比如缅因州的奥林匹亚·斯诺（Olympia Snowe）——正在退出，或者成为他们自己党派和右倾特殊利益团体的目标。
And this is happening at the state level too, even in some places that were deeply, famously moderate, places you would not expect moderates to get pushed out, like New Hampshire. Sarah Koenig explains.
这也发生在州一级，即使是在一些非常著名、非常温和的地方，那些你根本没预料到温和派会被挤走的地方，比如新罕布什尔州。莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）来解释。
I learned about New Hampshire's turmoil from my friend Annmarie Timmins. She's a reporter at the Concord Monitor newspaper in New Hampshire. I used to work there too. That's how we met.
我是通过我的朋友安玛丽·蒂明斯（Annmarie Timmins）了解到新罕布什尔州的动荡的。她是新罕布什尔州《康科德监测报》的记者。我过去也在那里工作。我们就是这样认识的。
She grew up in New Hampshire. Her parents grew up in New Hampshire. I kind of think of Annmarie as New Hampshire. She's moderate in all things-- an "early to bed, early to rise," "treat others with respect" sort of person. By her own admission, she's a little old-fashioned, a bit of a Miss Manners, like New Hampshire. For instance, each town in the state holds an annual meeting where the residents vote directly on the local budget. Here's Annmarie.
她在新罕布什尔州长大。她的父母也在新罕布什尔州长大。我有点把安玛丽看作是新罕布什尔州的化身。她在所有事情上都很温和——一个“早睡早起”、“以礼待人”的人。用她自己的话来说，她有点老派，有点像艾米丽·波斯特（Miss Manners），就像新罕布什尔州一样。例如，州里的每个镇都会举行年度会议，居民们直接投票决定当地预算。这是安玛丽。
I mean, I've been to town meetings where there's a little swear jar. If you swear or are rude, you have to put a quarter in. And so if someone says something or cuts someone off or is rude, they walk up with their quarter and they put it in. And it's sort of funny, but they also take it seriously. And they speak nicely to one another.
我的意思是，我参加过镇会议，那里有一个小小的“脏话罐”。如果你骂人或粗鲁，你必须放进去一枚25美分硬币。所以如果有人说了什么或打断某人或粗鲁，他们会走上来放进他们的硬币。这很有趣，但他们也把它当回事。而且他们彼此说话都很客气。
And the same was more or less true at the state House, which is remarkable for its size. It's got a little Senate of 24 people but then an enormous House with 400 members. And this in one of the smallest states in the country-- so that in some places, you could get elected with a grand total of, say, 650 votes and a campaign investment of maybe $200 or maybe nothing. Literally, you could spend nothing and get elected to the New Hampshire House. A truly representative democracy, reflecting the New Hampshire state tradition. You don't pry into each other's affairs, you don't ask people how much money they make, and you may not like what they're doing in the bedroom, but it's understood to be none of your business.
州议会也差不多是这样，其规模之大令人瞩目。它有一个24人的小参议院，但有一个400名成员的庞大众议院。这还是在这个国家最小的州之一——所以有些地方，你可能总共获得比如650张选票和大概200美元的竞选投入，或者什么都没有，就能当选。实际上，你可能一分钱不花就能当选进入新罕布什尔州众议院。这是一个真正的代表性民主，反映了新罕布什尔州的传统。你不窥探别人的私事，不问别人赚多少钱，而且你可能不喜欢他们在卧室里做的事，但大家都明白那不关你的事。
This Libertarian sort of, I'll live my life, you live your life, we won't have a sales or income tax, and that's the New Hampshire way. And you could hash things out and be friends at the end. And it's just not that anymore.
这种“我过我的生活，你过你的生活，我们不会有销售税或所得税”的自由意志主义，就是新罕布什尔的方式。你可以把事情讨论清楚，最后还是朋友。但现在情况已经不是这样了。
[RALLYING]
[集会现场声]
Exhibit A. For the past couple of years, Annmarie has watched her state, the swear jar state, descend into a kind of knee-bashing, "you're either with us or against us" politics that used to exist someplace else-- on TV, maybe, or in Washington, DC. This is footage of a rally against the Speaker of the New Hampshire House, Bill O'Brien, when he went to Portsmouth to deliver a speech to a Republican women's group.
例证A。过去几年里，安玛丽看着她的州，那个“脏话罐”之州，堕落成了一种磕磕碰碰、“非友即敌”的政治氛围，这种政治过去只存在于别处——可能在电视上，或者在华盛顿特区。这是针对新罕布什尔州众议院议长比尔·奥布莱恩（Bill O'Brien）的抗议集会录像，当时他去朴茨茅斯向一个共和党女性团体发表演讲。
Thank you for calling me a pig.
感谢你叫我猪。
I didn't call you a pig.
我没叫你猪。
No, you did. You did. You called him a pig. If you call him one, you call me one.
不，你叫了。你叫了。你叫他猪。如果你叫他猪，那你就是在叫我。
You liar.
你这个骗子。
In case you can't hear it, that dialogue-- it's the speaker and another state rep and a former state senator-- it went like this. "Thank you for calling me a pig." "I did not call you a pig." "You did. You did. You called him a pig. You call him one, you call me one." "You liar."
如果你听不清，那段对话——那是议长、另一位州议员和一位前州参议员——是这样的：“感谢你叫我猪。”“我没叫你猪。”“你叫了。你叫了。你叫他猪。你叫他猪，那你就是在叫我。”“你这个骗子。”
Can I just say, as someone who used to cover the New Hampshire state House for the Concord Monitor , this scene is shocking-- the very fact that the rally is aimed at the House Speaker. When I was covering the legislature, most people couldn't have told you the House Speaker even was. I will tell you who it was. It was Donna Sytek, a no-nonsense Republican who felt so strongly about political etiquette that she wrote a book about it, with chapters such as Decorum at the Event and Say Thank You. Now there's less and less decorum at the event.
我能说一句吗，作为曾经为《康科德监测报》报道新罕布什尔州众议院的人，这一幕令人震惊——集会的目标竟然是众议院议长。当我报道议会时，大多数人甚至说不出众议院议长是谁。我可以告诉你那是谁。是唐娜·赛泰克（Donna Sytek），一位非常务实的共和党人，她对政治礼仪的坚持非常强烈，以至于她写了一本关于它的书，章节包括《活动中的礼仪》和《学会说谢谢》。现在，活动中的礼仪越来越少了。
New Hampshire is such a small place, and the change here happens so quickly and thoroughly. You can see very clearly how hard it is for people in the middle to hang on. What happens when the middle disappears?
新罕布什尔州是一个很小的地方，这里的变化发生得如此迅速而彻底。你可以非常清楚地看到中间派想要坚持下去有多难。当中间派消失时，会发生什么？
So what happened? Well, New Hampshire is in the grip of a sudden ideological whiplash. Just like in Washington, the Democrats had a recent moment on top. In 2006, they won majorities in both houses of the New Hampshire legislature, the first time since the mid-1800s. And they did what Democrats do-- increased spending for their priorities and they legalized gay marriage.
那么发生了什么？嗯，新罕布什尔州正处于一种突然的意识形态剧变中。就像在华盛顿一样，民主党最近有幸掌权过。2006年，他们在议会两院都赢得了多数席位，这是自19世纪中期以来的第一次。他们做了民主党人通常做的事——增加了优先事项的支出，并使同性婚姻合法化。
Then four years later in the 2010 election, when Democrats took a shellacking nationwide, the same thing happened in New Hampshire. Republicans swept in. They won not just majorities but super majorities in both houses. Republicans dominated Democrats three to one. The GOP leaders vowed to undo what they called the, quote, "four-year assault" the Democrats had launched on the state. They were going to rethink what government should even be doing.
四年后的2010年选举中，当民主党人在全国范围内惨败时，同样的事情也发生在新罕布什尔州。共和党人席卷而来。他们不仅赢得了多数席位，而且在两院都赢得了绝对多数。共和党人以三比一的优势压倒了民主党人。共和党领导人誓言要撤销他们所谓的民主党对该州发起的为期四年的“攻击”。他们要重新考虑政府到底应该做什么。
The voters had elected about 160 new Republican members, a huge band of newcomers. And they were a fired-up population-- Tea Partiers and hardcore Libertarians and Christian conservatives and Free Staters. Free Staters are a movement unto themselves-- people from elsewhere who'd picked up and moved to New Hampshire in the past decade with the express intention of getting elected and transforming government into the tiniest institution possible.
选民们选出了大约160名新的共和党成员，这是一群庞大的新人。他们是一群充满干劲的人——茶党人士、强硬的自由意志主义者、基督教保守派和“自由州人”（Free Staters）。“自由州人”是一个独立的运动——过去十年里，来自其他地方的人搬到新罕布什尔州，明确意图是当选并将政府改造成尽可能微小的机构。
Many of these Republican freshmen didn't want to sit back and learn. Like the Republicans who swept into DC in 2010, they wanted action now. They bucked tradition, they bucked leadership, they were defiant.
许多这些共和党新生并不想坐下来学习。就像2010年席卷华盛顿的共和党人一样，他们现在就要行动。他们挑战传统，挑战领导层，他们充满了反叛精神。
And I think that caused a great deal of frustration.
我认为这引起了巨大的挫折感。
Meet George Lambert, one of these newcomers.
见见乔治·兰伯特（George Lambert），这些新人中的一员。
Because they're like, well, you don't know how things work. And my response to that, and the response of a lot of people like me, is you're absolutely right. We got elected because people didn't like the way that things were working.
因为他们说：“嗯，你不了解事情是如何运作的。”而我对那的回应，以及许多像我这样的人的回应是：你说得完全对。我们当选是因为人们不喜欢事情运作的方式。
Lambert's 44, a computer guy. He's not a big fan of government in general. In the past two years, Lambert sponsored or cosponsored bills to prohibit vaccinations in public schools, allow nonviolent felons access to firearms, get rid of sobriety checkpoints, and outlaw speed limits.
兰伯特44岁，是个搞电脑的人。他总体上不是政府的大粉丝。过去两年里，兰伯特发起或共同发起了禁止公立学校接种疫苗、允许非暴力重罪犯拥有枪支、取消清醒检查站和废除限速的法案。
By the time O'Brien took over as speaker, the alchemy of the House had changed so much there was no telling what could pass. It seemed like everything was on the table, even stuff that had been long settled in the state-- public schools, several bills to limit abortions, bills to get rid of all sorts of gun licensing, also the repeal of gay marriage. On day one of the 2011 legislative session, a day for symbolism and legislative good cheer, there was this.
当奥布莱恩接任议长时，众议院的化学反应已经改变得如此之大，以至于没人知道什么能通过。看起来所有事情都在谈判桌上，甚至是州里长期确定的事情——公立学校、几项限制堕胎的法案、取消各种枪支许可的法案，还有废除同性婚姻。在2011年立法会议的第一天，一个象征性和立法上充满欢乐的日子，发生了这样的事。
We shall be allowed to protect ourselves on the House floor by having the ability to have a concealed weapon on the floor, in the anteroom, in the gallery.
我们应该被允许通过在议会大厅、前厅、画廊拥有携带隐藏武器的能力来保护自己。
Yep. On day one, they voted to allow guns in the state House. And remember, there are 400 of these people. This new rule has led to some really weird moments, like when a rep named Kyle Tasker dropped his gun in the middle of a criminal justice and public safety committee hearing. Annmarie was there.
是的。在第一天，他们投票允许在州议会携带枪支。记住，这些人有400个。这一新规定导致了一些非常奇怪的时刻，比如当一位叫凯尔·塔斯克（Kyle Tasker）的议员在刑事司法和公共安全委员会听证会中间掉落了他的枪。安玛丽就在那里。
He was situating himself in his seat, and he kind of scooted forward. And there was this clang. And people were like, was that his gun? I had to check. I said, did that really just happen? He did drop his gun, right? That's what it was? Because there was no discussion about it, no break in the meeting, didn't clear the room-- nothing. Nothing.
他正在调整座位，有点往前挪。然后就出现了“哐当”一声。人们问：“那是他的枪吗？”我不得不确认。我说：“那真的刚才发生了吗？他确实掉了他的枪，对吧？就是那玩意儿，对吧？”因为对此没有任何讨论，会议也没有中断，也没有清理房间——什么都没有。什么都没有。
I had just given blood, and I might not have latched it quite properly.
我刚才献了血，可能没挂好。
Representative Kyle Tasker.
代表凯尔·塔斯克。
All I could think was, yeah, that was bound to happen one of these days. I come here too often for that not to have happened.
我唯一能想到的是，是的，总有一天会发生这种情况。我来这里的次数太频繁了，不发生才怪。
Yep, that was bound to happen. I spoke to another rep whose entire holster, with gun, fell off right outside the state House. He never brought his gun again after that, though he didn't want me to tell anyone since he'd like people to think he carries all the time, keep them on their toes.
是的，那一定会发生的。我和另一位议员谈过，他的整个枪套连同枪在州议会大厦外掉出来了。从那以后他再也没带过枪，尽管他不想让我告诉任何人，因为他想让人们以为他一直带着枪，保持警惕。
During the first year of this new regime, the Republicans managed something extraordinary. They'd vowed to slash government spending and not raise any taxes or fees. And they actually did it. They shrunk the budget by nearly 11% and lowered the cigarette tax to boot. They turned the budget process on its head, adding up revenues first and then axing whatever they couldn't pay for. The result, funding for the University of New Hampshire cut nearly in half, hospital funding cut by at least $250 million, assistance to needy families cut by something like $14 million. These are big, big numbers in New Hampshire. Attached to the budget were the same kinds of anti-union measures you saw in Wisconsin and other states, and they resulted in the same kind of blow back.
在这个新政权的第一年，共和党人完成了一些非凡的事情。他们誓言要削减政府开支，不增加任何税收或费用。他们真的做到了。他们将预算缩减了近11%，还顺便降低了香烟税。他们把预算过程倒转过来，先加总收入，然后砍掉任何他们支付不起的东西。结果，新罕布什尔大学的资助减半，医院资助至少削减了2.5亿美元，对贫困家庭的援助削减了约1400万美元。这些在新罕布什尔州都是非常庞大的数字。预算中附加了你在威斯康星州和其他州看到的同样的工会反制措施，结果也导致了同样的反弹。
What's disgusting?
什么是令人作呕的？
Union busting.
打击工会。
All right. Security? Clear the hall. Clear the hall! Get out.
好了。安全？清理大厅。清理大厅！滚出去。
Union busting.
打击工会。
This is from a finance committee hearing. The day of the actual budget vote, screaming protesters covered the State House lawn and filled the House gallery. The puffed-up rhetoric that day was especially puffy. Here's then-Republican Majority Leader DJ Bettencourt.
这是在财政委员会听证会上。实际预算投票的那天，愤怒的抗议者覆盖了州议会草坪并填满了众议院画廊。那天夸张的言辞特别多。这是当时共和党多数党领袖DJ·贝滕库尔特（DJ Bettencourt）。
Never in the years, Mr. Speaker, that I have been in this House--
议长先生，在我进入众议院的这些年来，从未——
Bettencourt was all of 27 years old, by the way.
顺便说一句，贝滕库尔特当时才27岁。
--have I ever heard such outrageous and exaggerated political hyperbole engulf a budget proposal such as we have seen here. With terms as extreme as immoral and evil, what a disgrace.
——听到过像我们在这里看到的预算提案那样被如此恶劣和夸张的政治修辞所吞没。用“不道德”和“邪恶”这样极端的术语，真是丢人。
Like every revolution, this one had a leader-- House Speaker Bill O'Brien. No question, he's been the lightning rod for pretty much everything that's happened, good or bad, in the past two years. According to Fergus Cullen, a former state GOP chairman, O'Brien recruited dozens of the new freshmen in 2010. Quote, "What Bill was trying to do was not only fill seats," he said, "but to find people who are ideological-- you know, the right kind of Republican. He wanted the strongest anti-Obama types." Unquote.
像每一场革命一样，这一场也有一个领导者——众议院议长比尔·奥布莱恩。毫无疑问，他是过去两年里无论好坏几乎所有事情的避雷针。据前共和党主席弗格斯·卡伦（Fergus Cullen）说，奥布莱恩在2010年招募了几十名新的大一新生。引用：“比尔试图做的不仅是填补席位，”他说，“而是寻找那些具有意识形态的人——你知道，那种真正的共和党人。他想要最强硬的反对奥巴马类型的人。”不引了。
And when O'Brien ran for Speaker after only four years in the House, these new folks supported him, upending the establishment. Ever since, O'Brien's been a guy who elicits all variety of superlatives. These next few voices all belong to Republicans. Actually, every lawmaker you'll hear in this story is a Republican.
当奥布莱恩在众议院仅工作四年后就竞选议长时，这些新人支持了他，颠覆了建制派。从那以后，奥布莱恩一直是一个引起各种最高级形容词的人。接下来这些声音都属于共和党人。事实上，你在故事中听到的每一位立法者都是共和党人。
That man has more integrity than anyone I've met in government ever.
那个人比我见过政府中的任何人都更有正直感。
Our Republican Party has been hijacked by Bill O'Brien and his thugs. They're nasty. They're mean. I have never encountered such bullying.
我们的共和党被比尔·奥布莱恩和他的暴徒劫持了。他们很刻薄。他们很卑劣。我从未遇到过如此的霸凌。
The definition of a cult leader is somebody that can get people to bend their will to succumb to them, and we're seeing more and more of that.
邪教领袖的定义是一个能让人们弯曲意志屈服于他们的人，我们越来越多地看到了这一点。
He's a great Speaker. He's probably the best tool that the Republicans have to accomplish a conservative agenda in the state.
他是一位伟大的议长。他可能是共和党人用来完成保守议程的最佳工具。
That's George Lambert, Susan Emerson, Lee Quandt, and Bob Meade. I don't know if an unbending, take-no-prisoners style is required to achieve radical change in a State House. But in New Hampshire, the two have gone hand in hand. Arguably, the Speaker's in charge of marshaling an unwieldy coalition. The Libertarians don't always agree with the Free Staters who don't always agree with the conservatives. So maybe a firm hand is the only way to get anything done at all.
那是乔治·兰伯特、苏珊·艾默生（Susan Emerson）、李·坎特（Lee Quandt）和鲍勃·米德（Bob Meade）。我不知道在州议会实现激进变革是否需要不屈不挠、不留俘虏的风格。但在新罕布什尔州，两者齐头并进。可以说，议长负责统领一个笨重的联盟。自由意志主义者并不总是同意“自由州人”的观点，而“自由州人”也不总是同意保守派。所以也许强硬手段是完成任何事情的唯一途径。
In any case, what's clear is that if you cross the speaker, especially on something he cares about, he will not take it lying down. Two Republican reps who angered the speaker-- one an ex-cop injured on the job, the other in a wheelchair-- were both denied aisle seats. And no, the latter was not allowed to reach over to his assigned spot and press his voting button with his cane.
无论如何，可以肯定的是，如果你惹恼了议长，尤其是关于他在乎的事情，他不会坐视不理。两名激怒议长的共和党代表——一位是在工作中受伤的前警察，另一位坐在轮椅上——都被拒绝提供过道座位。不，后者不被允许伸手到他指定的座位，用他的手杖按下他的投票按钮。
Representative Susan Emerson got into a ferocious and well-publicized fight with Speaker O'Brien last year. Fun fact about Susan Emerson-- she has over 700 hats stored in plastic bins in her barn. She wears a different one every single day. Anyway, last year when the House was getting ready to debate the budget, Emerson objected to a bunch of cuts in services for the poor and mentally ill. She planned to bring an amendment to the House floor to restore the money. That apparently was a no-no.
苏珊·艾默生议员去年与奥布莱恩议长进行了一场激烈且广为人知的争吵。关于苏珊·艾默生的趣事——她在谷仓的塑料盒里存放了超过700顶帽子。她每天都戴不同的帽子。总之，去年当众议院准备辩论预算时，艾默生反对削减贫困人口和精神病患者的服务。她计划向众议院提出一项修正案以恢复这笔钱。那显然是被禁止的。
And O'Brien comes over. I can still hear his feet pitter-patting up the aisle, and he said, Emerson, outside now.
奥布莱恩过来了。我还能听到他沿着过道走过来的脚步声，他说：“艾默生，现在出去。”
He takes her across the hall into the Senate chamber and tells her in no uncertain terms to drop her amendment.
他把她带到大厅对面的参议院会议室，不容置疑地告诉她放弃她的修正案。
And he was just screaming. And I just couldn't get any words in. And I kept backing up because I thought O'Brien was going to hit me. He was two inches from my face. And I started crying.
他一直在尖叫。我根本插不上话。我一直往后退，因为我以为奥布莱恩要打我。他离我的脸只有两英寸。我开始哭了起来。
In the aftermath, Emerson got kicked off her committee, Health and Human Services, and ended up filing House Bill 1533, an act prohibiting bullying in the State House and Legislative Office Building. This fight had been the talk of Concord. And when it came time for the public hearing, other lawmakers came forward to say they'd been bullied too. Speaker O'Brien told the Nashua Telegraph , quote, "It pains me to say Representative Emerson has fabricated all of this." Unquote.
事后，艾默生被踢出了她的委员会——健康与人类服务委员会，最终提交了众议院第1533号法案，《禁止州议会和立法办公大楼内欺凌行为法案》。这场争吵成了康科德的热门话题。当举行公开听证会时，其他立法者站出来说他们也被霸凌过。奥布莱恩议长告诉《纳舒厄电报》，引用：“我说这让我很痛苦，艾默生议员编造了这一切。”不引了。
I think it's safe to say that what most of us want from our government is people thinking problems through on their merits, hashing out solutions. The place where that hashing out happens is the legislative committees. Anywhere from 800 to 1,000 bills are filed each term in the House. If you're a volunteer or citizen lawmaker, you're depending on the committees to figure out the details. They're the experts.
我想可以肯定地说，我们大多数人从政府中想要的是人们在优点基础上深思熟虑地解决问题，推敲出解决方案。这种推敲发生的地方就是立法委员会。每届众议院提交800到1000项法案。如果你是一名志愿者或公民立法者，你依赖委员会来弄清楚细节。他们是专家。
In New Hampshire, the committees had worked well, for the most part leaving posturing and party nonsense outside the room. I wondered if that was still true. Was give and take still allowed? Did they tolerate dissent? When I asked around, this was what most people complained about-- that this process is what broke down under the new agenda.
在新罕布什尔州，委员会运作良好，大部分时间将装模作样和政党废话排除在室外。我想知道那是否仍然是真的。给与取是否仍然被允许？他们容忍异议吗？当我四处打听时，这是大多数人抱怨的事情——这种过程在新议程下崩溃了。
Leadership didn't just want Republicans to win all committee votes. They wanted to win unequivocally. So Republican reps would be sent into committees just before votes, and these ringers would cast votes even when they hadn't heard a speck of testimony, and even on controversial bills like voter ID.
领导层不仅希望共和党人赢得所有委员会投票。他们希望赢得毫不含糊的胜利。所以共和党代表会在投票前被派进委员会，这些外援会在他们甚至没听过一点证词的情况下投票，甚至在选民身份证等有争议的法案上也是如此。
I heard several stories like this next one. David Welch is a Republican on the criminal justice and public safety committee. He's white haired and bearded and looks like he stepped out of the giant Civil War painting on the first floor of the State House. The look is by design. He's a reenactor, but not of the Civil War, it turns out.
我听过几个像下一个这样的故事。大卫·韦尔奇（David Welch）是刑事司法和公共安全委员会的共和党人。他白发苍苍，留着胡子，看起来就像是从州议会一楼那幅巨大的内战油画中走出来的一样。这种造型是故意的。他是个重现者，但不是内战的，事实证明。
I do French and Indian and Revolution. Civil War-- I never could get involved in the Civil War because you have to be a soldier. You have to wear a uniform, and everybody wants to be a general.
我做法国人和印第安人以及革命战争。内战——我从来没能参与内战，因为你必须是一名士兵。你必须穿制服，而且每个人都想当将军。
Welch was also in House leadership, a deputy whip. His committee was considering a bill-- well, I'll just read you the title. Quote, "an act making the touching or viewing with a technological device of a person's breasts or genitals by a government security agent without probable cause a sexual assault," unquote. Basically, it would make TSA agents at Manchester Airport subject to felony sex offender charges for using their equipment too freely. The committee thought it was a dumb bill, and they voted unanimously-- or near-unanimously, Welch can't quite remember-- to kill it.
韦尔奇也在众议院领导层中，是一名副党鞭。他的委员会正在审议一项法案——嗯，我直接读标题给你。引用：“一项使政府安全代理人在没有合理怀疑的情况下，通过技术设备触摸或查看某人的胸部或生殖器，构成性侵犯的法案。”引用。基本上，这将使曼彻斯特机场的TSA代理人因为使用设备过于随意而面临重罪性犯罪指控。委员会认为这是一个愚蠢的法案，他们一致——或者几乎一致，韦尔奇记不太清了——投票否决了它。
Well, evidently there was somebody in the room that was monitoring how the vote was going. And that individual went out and made a phone call. And then we were taken out of committee into a caucus.
嗯，显然房间里有人在监控投票情况。那个人出去打了个电话。然后我们被带离委员会参加了一个核心会议。
In other words, a meeting just for the Republicans.
换句话说，只是为共和党人准备的会议。
Which was the first time-- that was in 27 years-- first time that we've ever had a Republican caucus in my committee. That was like going to the woodshed.
这是第一次——那是27年来——第一次在我的委员会中有共和党核心会议。那就像去了“木棚”（挨训）。
Who was it? Who came and gathered you?
是谁？是谁来聚集你们的？
It was the speaker. And we were told that the bill has to come out of committee.
是议长。我们被告知该法案必须走出委员会。
Did anyone say, with all due respect, Mr. Speaker, we've looked at this legislation and it just doesn't make sense in its present form, or some polite way of saying, this is bad legislation? Did anyone argue?
有没有人说：“恕我直言，议长先生，我们已经看过这份立法了，它目前的形式说不通”，或者用某种客气的方式说这是糟糕的立法？有人辩论吗？
Three or four of us did, including me. But it didn't make any difference. He wanted it, so as the majority whip or the assistant majority whip, I came back into committee. I made a motion for reconsideration. And then I made a motion to pass the bill out.
我们中有三四个人，包括我在内。但没有任何区别。他想要它通过，所以作为多数党副党鞭，我回到了委员会。我提出了重新考虑的动议。然后我提出了通过该法案的动议。
How did you feel doing that?
你做那件事时感觉如何？
I'd rather not say. But I didn't feel good about it. But I did it.
我不想说。但我感觉不好。但我还是做了。
Did you feel ashamed?
你感到羞耻吗？
Somewhat.
有点。
It's not that strong-arm tactics were never used by previous speakers in New Hampshire. But most everyone told me that moves used rarely in the past, now they're almost expected. In speeches and press releases, Bill O'Brien doesn't hold back. He says Democrats, quote, "promote lies," judges are, quote, "politicians in black robes," unions, in his world, apparently only employ bosses or thugs, and the notion that gay marriage is a civil right, absurd.
并不是以前的新罕布什尔州议长从未施加过强硬手段。但几乎每个人都告诉我，过去很少使用的手段，现在几乎是预料之中的。在演讲和新闻稿中，比尔·奥布莱恩毫不退缩。他说民主党人，“推广谎言”，法官是，“身穿黑袍的政客”，工会，在他的世界里，显然只雇佣老板或暴徒，而同性婚姻是一种公民权利的观念，荒谬。
But he's much scarier on paper than he is in person. This is no Boss Hogg of the North. O'Brien is short and slight with a neat beard and an almost shy aspect. And he's got a nice, ready laugh, and he's witty and smart, like the attorney he is. His demeanor says, who me? I'm just here doing my part, advancing liberty, like any decent person would.
但他纸上谈兵比真人更可怕。这不是北方的“霍格老板”（Boss Hogg）。奥布莱恩个子矮小，留着整洁的胡子，显得有点害羞。他有一种好、随和的笑声，而且风趣、聪明，就像他作为律师那样。他的举止仿佛在说：“谁，我吗？我只是在这里尽我的那份力，促进自由，就像任何正派的人会做的那样。”
You know, this concept that somehow a speaker of a New Hampshire House can be the Svengali of New Hampshire politics is just really kind of at variance with what the New Hampshire House is all about.
你知道，这种认为新罕布什尔州众议院议长可以是新罕布什尔政治的催眠师（Svengali）的概念，真的与新罕布什尔州众议院的本质格格不入。
When I asked about the harsher brand of politics he's ushered in, about whether radical change requires it, about how he sees this legislative war, he simply disagreed with the premise of my question, that the town has gotten harsher. He did this time after time, and not disagreeably, like this.
当我问及他带来的更严厉的政治品牌，关于激进变革是否需要它，关于他如何看待这场立法战争时，他简单地不同意我问题的前提，即这个镇变得更严厉了。他一次又一次地这样做，而且并不让人不快，就像这样。
My thinking again is that the premise of your question is wrong.
我的想法再次是，你问题的前提是错误的。
He said the same thing when I asked him about his heavy-handedness with committees. And the allegations of bullying he shrugged off as inside baseball, part of the Democrat narrative to distract citizens from the issues they truly care about-- jobs, taxes, the budget; if he's brought something new to Concord, it's not bullying, it's a fresh set of eyes.
当我问他关于他对委员会的强硬手段时，他说了同样的话。而他把关于霸凌的指控轻描淡写地称为“内幕野球”（inside baseball），是民主党叙事的一部分，目的是转移公民对他们真正关心的问题的注意力——工作、税收、预算；如果他给康科德带来了什么新东西，那不是霸凌，而是一双新的眼睛。
I became speaker after two terms in the House. And that brought certain strengths. And among those strengths was I wasn't tied to the past. And so it allowed us to look at problems anew. And I think that may have been what is shocking to the system. And it may well be that there were those who said, they're encountering this huge deficit.
我在众议院工作两届后当选议长。这带来了某些优势。这些优势之一是我没有与过去捆绑在一起。因此，它使我们能够重新审视问题。我认为这可能就是让系统感到震惊的原因。而且很有可能，确实有人说：“他们面临着巨大的赤字。”
And we know what has happened in the past. There's a combination of cuts. There's a combination of tax increases. And we didn't do that. And I think that may well have been shocking to the system and invited the type of response, personal attacks, and so forth, that we've seen come. That's not dismissing the voters. It's not being harsh with the opposition. It is basically just keeping your promises.
我们知道过去发生了什么。这是削减开支和增加税收的组合。而我们没有那样做。我认为这可能让系统感到震惊，并引来了我们看到的个人攻击等回应。那不是对选民的蔑视。也不是对反对派的严厉。它基本上只是信守承诺。
In our conversation, O'Brien was disciplined about staying on message. Almost every topic ended up back at the balanced budget. What he's not as keen to discuss is the fact that much of these past two years has been consumed by trickier, less crowd-pleasing topics-- guns, unions, gay marriage, contraception, abortion. New Hampshirites who'd voted for the new guard to rein in spending, a big part of their appeal in this fiscally-minded state, ended up with a broader ideological agenda. And some of it was fringe-y, catering to people with a fundamental distrust of government.
在我们的谈话中，奥布莱恩在坚持主题方面很有纪律。几乎每个话题最终都回到了平衡预算上。他不太热衷于讨论的事实是，过去两年的大部分时间都被更棘手、不那么讨巧的话题所占据——枪支、工会、同性婚姻、避孕、堕胎。在这个财政思维占主导地位的州，投票给新政权以限制开支（这是他们吸引力的一大方面）的新罕布什尔州人，最终得到了更广泛的意识形态议程。其中一些很边缘化，迎合了那些对政府有根本不信任感的人。
For instance, O'Brien resurrected a committee that had been dormant for about a century. It's called the Redress of Grievance committee, and it's a straightforward concept. The committee is supposed to give citizens who believe they've been wronged by government a place to come and complain. In practice, though, it's mostly angry dads challenging child custody and divorce cases that the family court settled years ago.
例如，奥布莱恩恢复了一个已经沉睡了大约一个世纪的委员会。它叫“申冤委员会”（Redress of Grievance committee），这是一个直观的概念。委员会应该为那些认为自己被政府冤枉的公民提供一个抱怨的地方。但在实践中，这大多是愤怒的父亲挑战家庭法院多年前解决的儿童监护权和离婚案件。
What this court order says is that I'm not allowed to punish my son. I'm not allowed to parent my son. Mind you, his mother's sitting there on these telephone calls. The telephone calls are on speakerphone so she can monitor them. She's coaching him. I've heard her coaching--
这份法庭命令上说我不允许惩罚我的儿子。我不允许抚养我的儿子。记住，他的母亲坐在电话那头。电话是免提的，所以她可以监控它们。她在指导他。我听到了她的指导——
This man testified for about eight hours-- not the longest by a long shot, actually. Apparently there was one that went on for almost 20 hours. He aired intimate details of his family's life. And remember, this isn't in front of a court. He's talking to regular old legislators in a committee who are sympathetic to his grievances.
这个人作证了大约八个小时——实际上远不是最长的。显然有一个持续了近20个小时。他播报了他家庭生活中的私密细节。记住，这不在法庭面前。他是在委员会中对普通的立法者说话，他们对他的冤情表示同情。
According to one committee member, Tim Horrigan-- admittedly a Democrat-- a bunch of members don't show up for these hearings at all, but about half the members who do come feel that the judicial branch is a, quote, "vast conspiracy." The judges and another judicial officers who are accused of wrongdoing don't come to defend themselves, though occasionally someone will send a letter. So the committee really only ever hears one side of the story. Nevertheless, as in this man's case, the committee recommends all manner of impeachment investigations and rule changes.
根据一位委员会成员蒂姆·霍里根（Tim Horrigan）——诚然是一位民主党人——说，有一部分成员根本没参加这些听证会，但约有一半参加的成员觉得司法部门是一个，“巨大的阴谋”。被指控不法行为的法官和其他司法官员没有来为自己辩护，尽管偶尔会有人发信。所以委员会实际上只听到了故事的一面。尽管如此，正如在这个人的案例中，委员会建议进行各种弹劾调查和规则更改。
All told, Horrigan said, about half the Superior Court judges had been recommended for impeachment. And marital masters, the state's judicial experts, deciding the thorniest and most emotional of family cases-- divorces and child custody and the like-- nearly all of them had cases brought against them. Here's Deborah Rein. She worked as a marital master for almost 24 years before retiring in December. All these hearings, she says, are chilling for everyone who works in the family court system.
总而言之，霍里根说，大约一半的高级法院法官被建议弹劾。而婚姻大师，该州的司法专家，决定最棘手、最情绪化的家庭案件——离婚、儿童监护权等——几乎所有案件都针对他们。这是黛博拉·雷恩（Deborah Rein）。她在去年12月退休前做了近24年的婚姻大师。她说，所有这些听证会对于每个在家庭法院系统工作的人来说都是令人不寒而栗的。
We shouldn't be worried that the legislature is going to start telling judges how they should be handling cases. I don't know. It was really hard being part of this important branch of government that looked like it was just being dismantled.
我们不应该担心立法机关会开始告诉法官他们应该如何处理案件。我不知道。作为政府这个重要分支的一部分，看起来只是被拆除，真的很困难。
In June of 2011, the legislature voted to get rid of marital masters. Problem solved. After a year of all this, old-school, moderate New Hampshire Republicans had had enough. They insisted that New Hampshire voters didn't want this right wing agenda. Here's Dave Kidder. He's fifth generation in his town. His father was a beloved lawmaker before him.
2011年6月，立法机关投票废除了婚姻大师。问题解决了。经过一年的这些事情，老派、温和的新罕布什尔州共和党人受够了。他们坚称新罕布什尔州选民不想要这个右翼议程。这是戴夫·基德（Dave Kidder）。他是他镇上的第五代人。他的父亲曾在他之前是一位受人爱戴的立法者。
There's very few of us-- what we all call Rockefeller Republicans-- left. Everybody has just either become Democrats or they've gone to the right. And I ain't going. My poor mother would come right out of the ground if she thought I was ever going to be a Democrat. And I'm not going to kowtow to the right wing of the party because I don't think they're Republicans.
我们很少有人——我们都称之为“洛克菲勒共和党人”——留下了。每个人要么变成了民主党人，要么向右转了。我才不走。如果她认为我有一天会成为民主党人，我可怜的母亲会直接从地底下冒出来的。而且我不会向党内的右翼卑躬屈膝，因为我不认为他们是共和党人。
So Kidder and the other moderates started to meet privately to quietly, respectfully discuss, the way moderates do. They came up with a plan. They would team up with, yes, Democrats and Independents and form a bipartisan caucus down the middle. It had never been done before. If they could get 40 or 50 people to join, they'd be a force to be reckoned with.
所以基德和其他温和派开始私下见面，像温和派那样安静、尊重的讨论。他们想出了一个计划。他们将与——是的，民主党人和无党派人士——联手，在中间形成一个跨党派核心小组。这以前从未做过。如果他们能拉到40或50人加入，他们将是一股不可忽视的力量。
In May of this year, they announced themselves as Restore the Center. They held a press conference across the street from the State House. Cynthia Dokmo, a moderate Republican, was one of the organizers.
今年5月，他们宣布自己为“恢复中心”（Restore the Center）。他们在州议会大厦对面举行了新闻发布会。温和派共和党人辛西娅·多克莫（Cynthia Dokmo）是组织者之一。
And we were in the LOB, the Legislative Office Building, where press conferences are often held.
我们在LOB，立法办公大楼，那里经常举行新闻发布会。
Thank you, Cynthia. And thanks to all my friends and--
谢谢你，辛西娅。也感谢我所有的朋友和——
And I believe it was Dr. Jim Squires that was speaking.
而且我相信是吉姆·斯奎尔斯（Jim Squires）博士在发言。
I'm here today because I believe a great danger lurks within the politics of our nation and state.
我今天在这里是因为我相信危险潜伏在我们国家和州的政治中。
And in the middle of it, all of a sudden, most of the reporters just got phone calls, and they ran out of room.
就在那中间，突然间，大多数记者接到了电话，他们跑出了房间。
--gauntlets and--
——护手和——
You can hear people shuffling around, doors swinging, as they head across the street.
你可以听到人们在挪动，门在摇摆，当他们穿过街道时。
I knew something had happened because they don't usually just run off in the middle of someone speaking.
我知道发生了什么，因为他们通常不会在别人发言到一半时跑掉。
On one side of the street, speeches about the dire need for civility, compromise, consensus. On the other side of the street, an explosion of incivility, a show-stopper. Representative Steve Vaillancourt, a Republican, had challenged the Speaker's treatment of a Democrat during a floor debate.
街道的一边，关于对礼仪、妥协、共识的迫切需求演讲。街道的另一边，一场缺乏礼仪的爆炸，一场中断节目。史蒂夫·瓦扬库尔（Steve Vaillancourt）议员，一位共和党人，挑战了议长在一次大厅辩论中对民主党人的对待方式。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[混杂声音]
The Sergeant-at-Arms will bring Representative Vaillancourt to order.
纠察长将把瓦扬库尔议员带回秩序。
Are you going to treat everybody fairly or not?
你是打算公平对待每一个人还是不打算？
Representative Vaillancourt, another outburst like that, you'll be removed from the hall.
瓦扬库尔议员，再有一次那样的爆发，你将被逐出大厅。
Sieg heil.
胜利万岁（Sieg heil）。
Oh! Ooh. Ooh.
哦！喔。喔。
The Sergeant-at-Arms will remove Representative Vaillancourt from the hall.
纠察长将把瓦扬库尔议员带出大厅。
Well, they got the Sergeant-at-Arms, and he came and wanted to escort me out. And I refused to leave.
好吧，他们叫了纠察长，他过来想把我带出去。但我拒绝离开。
Republican rep Steve Vaillancourt.
共和党代表史蒂夫·瓦扬库尔。
The funny thing is all these virile young Libertarian Free Staters would have nothing to do with it. As you probably know, I sit in the back row. And the two people who came to shield me from the Sergeant-at-Arms was an 89-year-old woman from Manchester named Irene Messier and Julie Brown, who must be pushing 90 years old. These were the people, like mother hens, that weren't going to remove me. So what they eventually did was take the key away so I couldn't vote.
有趣的是，这些精力充沛的年轻自由意志主义“自由州人”对此一点办法都没有。正如你可能知道的，我坐在后排。而那两位过来保护我不被纠察长带走的人，是一位叫艾琳·梅西耶（Irene Messier）的89岁曼彻斯特妇女和朱莉·布朗（Julie Brown），她一定有90岁了。这些人，就像母鸡一样，不打算带我走。所以他们最终做的是把钥匙拿走，让我不能投票。
Now Vaillancourt claims he meant no offense with the sieg heil thing. I know. But just hear him out. He lived in Berlin for a time.
现在瓦扬库尔声称他说“胜利万岁”时并无恶意。我知道。但听听他怎么说。他在柏林住过一段时间。
And having studied German, to me sieg heil simply means victory. And as I was using it in relationship to the Speaker, it means Mr. Speaker, you have the power, so the victory is yours. I can't say anything. So sieg heil.
而且学习过德语，对我来说“胜利万岁”简单意味着胜利。当我在与议长的关系中使用它时，它的意思是：议长先生，你有权力，所以胜利是你的。我不能说什么。所以“胜利万岁”。
Oh, come on. You weren't meaning to conjure Adolf Hitler in that moment.
哦，算了吧。那一刻你没打算联想到阿道夫·希特勒。
Absolutely not.
绝对没有。
Oh, come on, Steve. The entire rest of America has that association with sieg heil, and you're saying that you did not have Adolf Hitler in your head when you said sieg heil?
哦，算了吧，史蒂夫。全美国其他人对“胜利万岁”都有那种联想，你是在说你说“胜利万岁”时脑子里没有阿道夫·希特勒吗？
Absolutely not, swear to God, did not cross my mind at all. But I do realize that some people associate sieg heil with the Nazis. That's why I probably would have been better, in retrospect, saying sic semper tyrannis. You're not going to ask me what that means?
绝对没有，对上帝发誓，完全没经过我的脑子。但我确实意识到有些人把“胜利万岁”与纳粹联系起来。这就是为什么回过头来看，我说“暴君以此为诫”（sic semper tyrannis）可能更好。你不会问我那是什么意思吧？
I-- well, go ahead.
我——好吧，继续。
You know what that means. It means as always with dictators.
你知道那是什么意思。它的意思是一如既往对待独裁者。
Members will come to order. The chair recognizes Representative Vaillancourt.
议员们请保持秩序。主席承认瓦扬库尔议员。
Thank you, Mr. Speaker. As I was saying before, I cannot apologize for anything I did not do. But I do apologize for using two German words, which I understand have negative ramifications. Perhaps three Latin words would have been better, so I will never use a German word again, including huetchenspiel, gnadige frau, or meine damen und herren. Thank you.
谢谢你，议长先生。正如我之前所说，我不能为我没做过的事道歉。但我为使用了两个德语单词道歉，我明白它们有负面的影响。也许三个拉丁单词会更好，所以我以后再也不会用德语单词了，包括huetchenspiel（帽子戏法）、gnadige frau（优雅女士）或meine damen und herren（女士们先生们）。谢谢。
The sieg heil moment caused what incivility almost always causes-- more incivility and then a communication breakdown. Here's what happened-- the Concord Monitor , Annmarie's paper, ran an editorial cartoon picturing Bill O'Brien with a Hitler mustache. The caption was, "if the mustache fits." Then, post-cartoon, Annmarie got shut out of a press conference which Speaker O'Brien held in his private office so that he could legally close the door in her face, while every other reporter in town streamed past her inside.
“胜利万岁”时刻造成了缺乏礼仪几乎总是造成的结果——更多的缺乏礼仪，然后是沟通中断。以下是发生的事情——安玛丽的报纸《康科德监测报》刊登了一幅编辑漫画，画的是留着希特勒胡子的比尔·奥布莱恩。标题是，“如果胡子合适的话”。然后，在漫画发表后，安玛丽被拒之门外参加奥布莱恩议长在他私人办公室举行的新闻发布会，以便他可以合法地把门关在她脸上，而镇上所有其他记者都在她面前流进了办公室。
Why can't we come into this press conference? The invite does not say invite only.
为什么我们不能进入这个新闻发布会？邀请函上没有写只邀请特定人员。
It wasn't sent to your organization. Can you move that way, please?
它没发给你们组织。请往那边移一下，好吗？
The entire media corps is here.
整个媒体机构都在这儿。
Excuse me. Matt, come in. Hi, Jamie. Are you waiting for him?
抱歉。马特（Matt），进来。嗨，杰米（Jamie）。你在等他吗？
And then one day, following this getting shut out of his office, the press releases stopped, and we would not be getting any more press releases, we would not be getting any more access to the speaker's office until we could behave like professional journalists.
然后有一天，在被拒之门外后，新闻稿停止了，我们再也收不到任何新闻稿，再也无法进入议长办公室，直到我们可以像专业记者一样行事。
Shutting out the capital paper from House business, that made national news. It's unprecedented in New Hampshire and most other places. Annmarie had told me about this back when it happened, but what I hadn't realized until now is that she'd never been able to speak to O'Brien, even from the beginning. Before they'd even been introduced, he'd made up his mind about her and about the newspaper. To him, it was just a mouthpiece for the Democrats. What was the point of a conversation?
拒绝首府报纸参加众议院事务，这上了全国新闻。在新罕布什尔州和其他大多数地方都是史无前例的。安玛丽在发生时曾告诉过我，但我直到现在才意识到，她甚至从一开始就没能和奥布莱恩说过话。在他们甚至还没被介绍之前，他就已经对她和报纸下定论了。对他来说，那只是民主党人的传声筒。谈话有什么意义呢？
I don't want our state to become-- there's this saying in the court system that you can always tell when a lawyer from Massachusetts is in a New Hampshire court because they're so combative. I don't want my state to become like a Massachusetts lawyer in a New Hampshire court. But I understand if the people of the state are aware of what's going on and they're paying attention and they are fine with that, then I'm not in the majority.
我不希望我们的州变成——法院系统里有这么一句话，你总是能看出马萨诸塞州的律师什么时候在新罕布什尔州的法庭里，因为他们太好斗了。我不希望我的州变成新罕布什尔州法院里的马萨诸塞州律师。但我理解，如果州里的人意识到正在发生什么，他们关注着，而且他们没问题，那我就不是多数派了。
The GOP primary in September was the first real test of whether voters were liking this new style of Republican politics. In the results, moderates took a beating. More than ever before, they were attacked with PAC money from inside and outside the state and by their own party. In a place where campaigning for the House used to mean buying some lawn signs and calling it a day, now just like in small races all over the country, there are great big signs on the road sides and slick attack mailers and mysterious money flowing in.
9月份的共和党初选是选民是否喜欢这种新式共和党政治的第一次真正测试。在结果中，温和派遭到了重创。他们比以往任何时候都受到来自州内和州外PAC资金以及他们自己党派的攻击。在一个为众议院竞选曾经意味着买些草坪标志然后结束的地方，现在就像全国各地的小型竞选一样，路边有巨大的标志，油滑的攻击性邮件，还有神秘的资金流动。
The mailers largely targeted Republicans who voted against New Hampshire's right-to-work bill, a union-weakening measure, based on model legislation written by ALEC, the American Legislative Exchange Council. These ads were paid for by groups like Americans for Prosperity, the Tea Party group that's funded nationally by the Koch brothers. Right-to-work was Speaker O'Brien's priority in New Hampshire and AFP's priority. But it didn't survive the governor's veto. Here's moderate Dave Kidder again.
这些邮件主要针对投票反对新罕布什尔州《工作权法案》（right-to-work bill，一项弱化工会的措施）的共和党人，该法案基于美国立法交流委员会（ALEC）撰写的范例立法。这些广告由像“美国繁荣”（Americans for Prosperity）这样的团体支付，这是一个在全国范围内由科赫兄弟资助的茶党团体。《工作权法案》是奥布莱恩议长在新罕布什尔州的优先事项，也是AFP的优先事项。但它没能活过州长的否决。这是温和派戴夫·基德。
Democrats they don't mind. It's the moderate Republicans that they really, really despise.
民主党人他们不介意。他们真正、真正鄙视的是温和派共和党人。
So they'd rather have a Democrat elected than you?
所以他们宁愿选出民主党人也不愿选你？
Correct. That's why we talk about the Republicans eating their own. This is exactly what we're talking about. And it's just crazy.
正确。这就是为什么我们谈论共和党人“同室操戈”。这就是我们所说的。这太疯狂了。
A few long-time moderates lost their primaries, like Julie Brown, the elderly lady who shielded Vaillancourt from the Sergeant-at-Arms, while a few others squeaked by. The primary knocked out some old-school conservative Republicans too, like the war reenactor David Welch after 14 terms in the House. He said after he refused to take a walk on the right-to-work, vote, O'Brien warned him there would be consequences.
一些长期的温和派在初选中落败，比如在纠察长面前保护瓦扬库尔的那位老妇人朱莉·布朗，而其他一些人以微弱优势险胜。初选也淘汰了一些老派的保守派共和党人，比如众议院任职14届的战争重演者大卫·韦尔奇。他说在拒绝在《工作权法案》投票中“走开”后，奥布莱恩警告他会有后果。
Susan Emerson, the lady who got yelled at, had eight different mailers targeting her. That's unheard of in New Hampshire. The mailers depict her as a union toady and a big fat taxer and spender. Here's moderate Republican Alida Millham.
被大吼大叫的苏珊·艾默生有八种不同的邮件针对她。这在新罕布什尔州是闻所未闻的。这些邮件把她描绘成工会的哈巴狗和一个大胖税收者和支出者。这是温和派共和党人阿丽达·米勒姆（Alida Millham）。
It's interesting being a target. I mean, I'm a pretty mild person.
成为目标很有趣。我的意思是，我是个很温和的人。
She decided not to run again this time around, despite her reputation as a consensus builder on the Health and Human Services committee. She feels like ever since moderate has become a bad word in New Hampshire politics, her talents don't matter anymore. She's become useless. And ideology, she said, doesn't need to deliberate. No one's listening.
尽管她在健康与人类服务委员会作为共识建立者享有盛誉，她还是决定这次不再竞选了。她觉得自从温和派在新罕布什尔州政治中成为贬义词以来，她的才能不再重要了。她变得毫无用处。她说，意识形态不需要审议。没有人听。
I think that there was a point time when I thought, well, that's a role that I fill is hey, we'll take this from this and this from that and see if we can make something work. But that doesn't exist anymore. And it's, oh, we don't want anybody in the middle. We want our one bite at the apple, and we want it all.
我想曾经有一个点，我想，好吧，我扮演的角色是“嘿，我们从这儿拿这个，从那儿拿那个，看看我们能不能让事情奏效”。但那不存在了。然后是，哦，我们不想要任何中间派。我们想要我们在苹果上咬一口，而且我们想要全部。
Looked at one way, what's happened in New Hampshire in the past two years is a coarsening of debate, a cheapening of government. But looked at another way, it's democracy doing what it should-- reflecting a new set of values from the ground up. After all, Bill O'Brien and his cohort didn't seize power. They were elected. And the question this election will answer is, is all this an aberration, or is this just the new New Hampshire?
从一个角度看，过去两年新罕布什尔州发生的事情是辩论的粗俗化、政府的廉价化。但从另一个角度看，这是民主在做它应该做的事——从基层反映出一套新的价值观。毕竟，比尔·奥布莱恩和他的追随者并没有夺取权力。他们是被选出来的。而这次选举将回答的问题是，所有这一切是一种异常，还是这只是新罕布什尔州的新面貌？
If you look at polls from the University of New Hampshire Survey Center, this is what you learn. Voters are split over whether the legislature is doing a good job, split over how it handled the budget, though a majority say the state is heading in the right direction. They're with the legislature on right-to-work but against it on the repeal of gay marriage. Interestingly, and the pollster calls this, quote, "a significant change," when people were asked to list the biggest problems facing the state, Republicans in the legislature has consistently made it into the top five since May of 2011.
如果你看看新罕布什尔大学调查中心的民调，这就是你所了解到的。选民们对议会是否做得好存在分歧，对它如何处理预算也存在分歧，尽管多数人说该州正在朝着正确的方向前进。他们在《工作权法案》上与议会保持一致，但在废除同性婚姻上反对它。有趣的是，民调专家称此为，“重大变化”，当人们被要求列出该州面临的最大问题时，自2011年5月以来，议会中的共和党人一直跻身前五名。
If the numbers seem contradictory, it's maybe because the last couple of years has been such a new and confounding experience for New Hampshire. One person compared it to what things felt like during the Civil Rights movement, which is maybe a little overblown. But they're similar in this way-- it's such a fundamental rethinking of what kind of place New Hampshire wants to be, and the two sides are so far apart that until they all agree on where they're going, it's going to be ugly.
如果数字看起来矛盾，也许是因为过去几年对新罕布什尔州来说是一次如此新鲜且令人困惑的经历。有人把它比作民权运动期间的情况，这可能有点夸张了。但它们有相似之处——这就是新罕布什尔州想要成为什么样的地方的一次根本性的重新思考，双方相距太远，以至于在他们都同意去向之前，情况会很难看。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our program. Miki Meek helped record that story.
莎拉·柯尼格是我们节目的制作人之一。美希·米克（Miki Meek）协助录制了那个故事。
[MUSIC- "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND" BY SHARON JONES & THE DAP KINGS]
[音乐 - 沙伦·琼斯和达普国王乐队演唱的《这片土地是你的土地》]
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, production help from Tarek Fouda. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由莎拉·柯尼格与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作的。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），制作助理是塔雷克·福达（Tarek Fouda）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddes）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International, and instead of hearing from our boss at WBEZ, Torey Malatia this week, I thought it would be nice to play a real-life voice mail message from WBEZ's human resource manager, Dorse Kelly, who very well might be everybody's favorite WBEZ employee. She knows that I'm in New York City right now. She knows about the storm. She knows I'm an atheist. We have discussed our faiths. We do not agree about that stuff at all. She left me this message this week.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行，本周没有播放我们WBEZ老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）的声音，我想播放一条来自WBEZ人力资源经理多斯·凯利（Dorse Kelly）的真实语音邮件会很好，她很可能是大家最喜欢的WBEZ员工。她知道我现在在纽约市。她知道风暴的事。她知道我是个无神论者。我们讨论过我们的信仰。我们在那些事上一点也不一致。她本周给我留了这条信息。
Ira Glass, Dorse Kelly. Just calling to check on  you guys and see if you're OK. New York has been hit by the vengeance of the devil. So anyway, just calling to check and see if you guys are OK. All right? And I pray that all is well. Talk to you later. Bye bye.
艾拉·格拉斯，多斯·凯利。打电话来看看你们怎么样，看看你们还好吗。纽约受到了魔鬼的报复。所以不管怎样，只是打电话来看看你们还好吗。好吧？我祈祷一切都好。回头聊。拜拜。
Thanks, Dorse. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week.
谢谢，多斯。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
公共广播国际（PRI）。